[Music]
loser
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
bullying
definitely
not a topic back in the 90s
not a topic back in the 90s in brazil
where i grew up
but violence in the school was a reality
for many of us
i remember
a classmate with a lisp
he couldn't talk pronounce a single word
without being mocked
i remember
the cross i'd grow from the school bus
who was always alone ignored by the
other girls
in the yard there was always someone who
was
too
short too fat too tall too skinny to
something that had to be pointed out
me
i was too soft
too gentle
not aggressive enough for a boy
i didn't know i was gay at the age of
seven
but bullying was already a daily task of
endurance for me
i remember
entering the school in fear
never knowing when the insults would
start
i remember spending entire school breaks
locked in restrooms to protect myself
from punches
but
when punches happen
i was the one sent to the principal's
office
i still felt my throat burning and
tightening while i tried as much as i
could to
hold back my tears
boys don't cry
be a man ricardo
what that was supposed to mean
wasn't i a man
when good friends
try to defend me against bullies they
emphatically claim things like stop
he's not gay
of course i was happy to have someone
watching my back but when i
finally realized that actually
i was gay
the whole thing made me feel
embarrassed lonely
ashamed
my identity was denied even by those who
in theory were my side my friends
back home
the fear of disappointing my parents
kept me quiet how could mommy and daddy
be proud of a [ __ ]
because i was different
i blamed myself for being bullied
i was convinced that i didn't deserve a
place in the world
for relief
from the daily bullying at school i
turned myself to the make-believe world
of movies
thank god i had movies
edward scissorhands and forrest gump
proved that outliers could also drive
bad education brokeback mountain portray
larger visions of love encouraged me to
stand tall
no matter what i had to find a way to be
happy
here i am
cinema changed my life through my
favorite characters
i leave vicariously and learn
how to overcome prejudice
when it came time to choose a career go
to the university i wanted to help other
struggling teenagers to find comfort and
acceptance
i decided to do through cinema went to
film school and soon became an
international sales agent
my job
was selling films to
theatrical distributors
tv channels
and streaming platforms across the world
by negotiating film rights i could
choose what people would watch next
embracing diversity i couldn't give a
voice for those in oppression like me
but also foster cultural exchange
it's much easier to understand another
culture
if we have seen its people on the screen
before right
i was happy to represent rafiki a queer
coming of age from kenya where
homosexuality is still a crime
or baraka meets baraka a romantic comedy
from saudi arabia calling from freedom
in the region
i was proud of myself
but
as a professional of the film industry i
had to acknowledge how problematic films
could also be
while cinema helped me and many others
to embrace our identities
it also spread the stereotype of
masculinity that not only shaped and
normalized my aggressor's behaviors but
i also encourage them to be violent and
cruel
think about our
traditional heroes
batman
james bond
or the killing machines from the 80s and
90s
rumble robocop the terminator
apart from sarcastic jokes they don't
talk much never ask or answer questions
but
nobody knows what's going on in their
heads but all of a sudden
it's violence o'clock
they express themselves sending dozens
to hell
hasta la vista baby
but wait
bad communication skills and the
tendency to solve differences with
violence doesn't that sound like
bullying
sometimes i wonder who my aggressors
back in school are victimizing today
according to these statistics
more than 85 percent of the homicides in
the u.s were committed by men
and more than two-thirds of the women
killed in the country were shot by their
husbands in cases of domestic violence
instead of encouraging boys to be kind
and vulnerable
hollywood has to stimulate them to hone
muscles and ninja skills
spreading a toxic stereotype of
masculinity
the pressure to conform has prevented
men from sharing emotions and forced
them to forego
empathy
year after year
we have seen on the screen
the same old formulas
but hollywood now is investing in
diversity
here's the question
keeping the same old models
wouldn't just perpetuate the same old
violent stereotypes
white western men are no longer the only
ones around but violent characters are
still the coolest
on the big screen
the good news
is that on smaller screens
streaming platforms offered today more
than ever content from different
countries communities
and cultures
we are a click away
from films that depicts that convey
different definitions of man different
kinds of people and different ways of
living life
imagine
if as a child my colleagues and i have
had access to all these different ways
of living life
we would probably feel less
different less lonely
i would feel that yes i was a man a more
soft and gentle one but is still a man
who deserved a place in the world
the other kids in the school would
accept not only me
but the classmates of a lisp
the crowds i had grown from the school
bus
and all the other kids in the yard who
were choose something
we are
we still have a long way to go against
more than a century
of oppressive characters in films
but the growing diversity
on the screen is a beacon of hope for a
more empathetic society
as an audience i invite you today to be
curious
to explore new narratives
and to make space for people to be just
different
no violence of any kind even is
acceptable
let's make the world a more kind place
not only for struggling kids
but for all of us
thank you
[Music]
you